[Music]
hey it's alex and today i'm going to
show you how to make my chicken cordon
bleu bake
[Music]
cold on blue
so this recipe is kind of a cross
between a classic chicken cordon bleu
and a beef wellington so i had the
classic elements of a chicken cordon
bleu but instead of the breading outside
i did a puff pastry outside so the
chicken cordon bleu inside is all very
classic and traditional so you can
choose to season your breasts
individually but i just threw them on
the bowl and seasoned that on there just
to make it a little easier and faster
so you're going to want to pound out
your chicken breast until it's pretty
thin this will help you to roll it in
the next step if you happen to have a
metal mallet that's a really easy way
to make sure your chicken is pounded out
properly but there's other tools you can
use lying around in your house to make
sure you get that thin piece of chicken
i use a wooden spoon it takes a little
extra effort but it still works and you
could also use a cast iron skillet so i
layered this with a double layer of the
cheese
just to make sure you get that extra
ooey gooey cheesy center and actually
made for a pretty good visual at the end
[Music]
so to make the rolling process easier i
hung my chicken on a piece of plastic
wrap so once you roll it up you're able
to encase that in the plastic and roll
it even tighter you want a really tight
seal so rolling it back and forth will
help you achieve that you kind of want
to get all the air you can out of it and
tightly roll it and seal it on the edges
so they have a nice tight
little chicken
little chicken they look like little
like piggies
so putting the chicken back in the
fridge is an important step to allow the
chicken to kind of firm up and hold its
shape so now for the outside i used puff
pastry because that is classic to a beef
wellington i trim the puffed pastry down
just because with the individual wrap
chickens you don't want to have too much
extra puff pastry
cause it'll just be like too bready and
also it might not cook like all the way
through if there's a lot of extra kind
of bunched up right there so classically
in a wellington the puff pastry is
brushed with english mustard you could
really use any like mustard variety that
you like like a dijon or just a regular
yellow mustard but english mustard has a
ton of flavor and a really bright
vibrant yellow color and you can usually
find it at most grocery stores so once
your chickens are cooled and set pop
that right on the puff pastry and give
it a wrap now again if you have too much
extra puff pastry trim that off and then
you can tuck the sides under and kind of
fix it so it looks really nice the egg
wash will help your puff pastry get
really nice and brown and golden color
once it's baked so then it's time to get
a little fancy with it so in order to
create a nice design on the outside i
took a fork and kind of drew marks in
the puff pastry itself so i did the
lines one way and then i went back and
did it diagonally so it had a nice kind
of diamond pattern on the puff pastry so
once it bakes it looks really nice and
pretty then hit it with a little more
salt
and you're ready to bake salt bae that
ish
so you want to bake your rolls until of
course the chicken is cooked through now
this chicken will actually cook pretty
fast because it's pounded out so thin so
it just won't take as long to cook as
like a full piece of chicken breast
but you also are looking for a really
deep golden brown color on the puff
pastry to make sure it's all the way
cooked through
pounding out the chicken breasts and
rolling it up like this will help you
get that really beautiful spiral center
that every chicken cordon bleu should
have also what's great about using the
puff pastry as opposed to a classic
chicken cordon bleu breading is that
it's so much cleaner breading is often
pretty messy since you have like a lot
going on with the egg and the bread
crumbs and the flour
but this you get it all in one go and
no mess no fuss
it's what i like
this dish is also super show-stopping
it's a great dish for a dinner party
they're pretty big so you might not need
to eat the whole thing but they look
really fancy and they taste even better
hello my name is alvin and today i will
be showing you my recipe for chicken
parmesan stuffed garlic bread
[Music]
so this is definitely one of my more
crazier tasty recipes i sat on this
concept for like six months i'm not even
kidding i really want to combine garlic
bread with something else because
everybody likes garlic bread and garlic
bread should not be only a side dish it
deserves to be the main attraction i
want to combine it with something that's
like an entree so i was like oh what do
you eat garlic bread with uh meatballs
spaghetti pasta chicken parm oh chicken
parm sounds really good it's got
everything that garlic bread needs in a
best friend i was like i need to find a
way to make chicken parmesan mixed in
with garlic bread so my idea was that
instead of doing a whole chicken breast
i would cut chicken breast up into
smaller strips bread them fry them
separately so you almost have like these
little chicken tenders that you can work
with
[Music]
after that i would wrap each chicken
tender with a slice of mozzarella cheese
because that's what chicken farm needs
and then i would take this little like
chicken cheese cylindrical thingy and
put it inside a hollowed out baguette i
think that you need to make sure that
you get a baguette that is not too thin
because you're going to hollow it out
because you're going to hollow out the
baguette you need to make sure that you
take a really thin sharp knife and cut
out like the filling of the bread we
don't want to waste that you can use
that for croutons you know sometimes the
middle of the bread can be the best part
i ate way too much of it as a kid so
don't throw that away but just make sure
that you hollow out a big enough hole
that your fried chicken with the cheese
around it can fit in and i would cut
that into small pieces try to make sure
that when you cut your chicken it's
uniform all the way through because if
you start with a piece that's like too
wide at one end and too narrow the other
you might get like halfway into the
bread and then it's going to be like
nope i don't want to go in anymore and
then we'll stop once you perfectly fit
the chicken and the cheese inside the
baguette you want to make sure that you
line it all up cut them into about an
inch pieces because this is meant to be
hand-held food once you cut them up line
it on the tray brush some amazing garlic
butter that you make over the top which
is super super easy just some garlic
just some butter maybe some parsley if
you want for color be liberal you know
garlic bread whoever's eating it i don't
think they're trying to be on a diet so
and you don't and you also don't have to
tell them how much you put in it so
brush liberally it'll get absorbed it'll
be delicious nobody's gonna complain
everybody loves garlic bread after you
brush it with butter cover it with foil
or don't depending on how crispy you
want your garlic bread to bake it off
and you have this wonderful wonderful
finger food for your party what's great
about it is because you've made these
cuts and because you put them back
together in the oven the cheese is
actually going to help it all stick
together so when it comes to the table
and people pull it apart you get that
amazing signature tasty cheese pull that
i've spent way too long trying to get
sometimes i think you serve it with a
side of marinara sauce you have all the
elements of chicken parmesan and garlic
bread in one single bite which i think
is really really cool because it's a
handheld version of a usual dish that
requires a fork and a knife so i think
this is a great idea i wasn't sure if it
was gonna be too much work where
everybody was gonna be like this is
stupid like why would you ever do this
but eventually one day i was like you
know what alvin if you're not gonna make
this idea you'll probably go mad so i
buckled down i cooked the recipe i
edited the video and it actually turned
out to be
really really cool if you have a party
coming up and you want to make this dish
feel free to customize it however you
like if you end up making it let me know
post in the comments i want to see a
picture because i love when people make
my recipes so feel free to do it for any
party i will guarantee it's a crowd
pleaser so happy cooking
hi i'm alexis and i'm the senior food
specialist here at tasty today i'm going
to show you how to make my chicken
teriyaki crispy rice noodle bowl
[Music]
i love chicken teriyaki but it can often
feel so heavy to me and i wanted to make
it in a way that felt lighter and a
little more exciting so i think using
the fried noodles incorporating some of
these other really fresh toppings makes
it feel fresh and exciting while still
having that really incredible flavor
from the teriyaki sauce so to start this
recipe you're going to make the teriyaki
sauce it's really simple you're whisking
a few ingredients together and set it
aside
so i used really thin vermicelli noodles
for this so you want to make sure that
you're taking small portions of the
noodles off if you put the whole thing
in it's not going to fry correctly break
it apart take a handful of the dried
noodles before you start to fry you also
want to fry the noodles in batches so
that they all get evenly cooked if you
overcrowd the pan they're going to get
burnt so whenever you're frying you
really want to make sure it's the right
temperature so you get the right
consistency and that it cooks through we
tried find these noodles at different
temperatures
and too low and nothing happens they
just become like oily noodles if it's
too high the noodles will get brown
really fast so you really want to use a
thermometer
[Music]
so the rice noodles are going to cook
really really fast as soon as they've
expanded you can use a slotted spoon to
remove them onto a sheet tray once you
fry the vermicelli noodles they just get
this incredible crunch which i
personally love so once your noodles are
fried you can move on to the chicken
gonna salt and pepper the chicken
[Music]
add it to a wall
[Music]
and at this point then you're going to
add that reserved teriyaki sauce this
takes a few minutes and the chicken's
going to get really like shellacked with
this incredible sauce it's going to be
deep and flavorful and it's i mean it's
truly such a good sauce it just kind of
drink it if you wanted
i think the joy of this dish is that it
has a ton of flavor but that it's really
easy to do frying sure will take a few
minutes but honestly you could do this
for under an hour this could be a
weeknight meal that's more interesting
than take out and it's more interesting
than your usual chicken teriyaki
once you're done with the chicken you
can serve it over the noodles
[Music]
i added some stuff like snap peas
radishes scallions but you can top it
with whatever you like
you can also just make the chicken on
your own you could make the rice noodles
on their own and put other toppings
something like shrimp or vegetarian
stir-fry it's a really versatile recipe
these noodles are worth making on their
own the chicken teriyaki is worth making
on its own but if you make it and use
other ingredients other toppings let us
know in the comments we want to see what
you're making at home
[Music]
you